THAT SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER UP.
>> WOW, FASCINATING.
STEPHANIE PARKINSON, APPRECIATE
THE REPORTING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
SHORTLY BEFORE AIR TIME, I SPOKE
WITH ONE OF THE STUDENTS WHO WAS
IN HIS CLASSROOM WHEN SHOTS RANG
OUT.
17-YEAR-OLD SENIOR NAMED ADEN
PAGE.
ADEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WERE IN YOUR
CLASSROOM RIGHT BEFORE CLASS
BEGAN WHEN YOU HEARD SOMETHING.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> UM, WE HEARD TWO GUNSHOTS AND
AFTER THAT -- UM -- MY TEACHER
RAN TO THE ROOM, LOCKED IT.
WE BARRICADED.
AND THEN, WE COVERED THE WINDOWS
AND HID.
>> DID -- DID YOU KNOW THEY WERE
GUNSHOTS RIGHT AWAY?
>> UM, I JUST HEARD TWO BANGS,
AND THEN I SAW MY TEACHER RUN TO
THE ROOM, LOCK DOWN.
I WAS LIKE, OKAY, THIS IS A
SHOOTER.
>> SO, YOUR TEACHER REACTED VERY
QUICKLY.
UM, WHAT HAPPENED?
I UNDERSTAND THERE WAS ANOTHER
TEACHER IN THE ROOM, AS WELL.
>> YES.
ANOTHER TEACHER ENTERED JUST TO
GRAB SOME HAND SANITIZER
QUICKLY.
AND THEN, THE SHOTS CAME OFF AND
THEN SHE RAN IN.
>> AND I UNDERSTAND SHE CALLED
TO HER CLASSROOM BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T GET BACK TO HER
CLASSROOM.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT?
>> UM, BASICALLY, SHE WAS LIKE
CAN ANYBODY -- DOES ANYBODY HAVE
A FRESHMAN IN MY CLASS?
AND THEN, A STUDENT DID.
AND THEN, SHE USED HER PHONE TO
CALL THEM.
>> SO, SHE GOT THE -- THE PHONE
NUMBER OF A FRESHMAN IN HER
CLASS FROM A STUDENT IN YOUR
CLASS?
>> YEAH.
>> AND THEN, SHE WAS, WHAT,
TRYING TO GIVE INSTRUCTIONS TO
HER CLASS ABOUT WHAT TO DO?
>> UM, THE CLASS BASICALLY WENT
INTO LOCKDOWN ALREADY.
UM, THERE WAS A STUDENT INJURED
AND SHE WAS KIND OF INSTRUCTING
THEM AND SUPPORTING THEM AS
WELL.
>> SO, A STUDENT HAD BEEN --
HAD -- HAD BEEN SHOT IN THAT
CLASSROOM?
>> YES, HE WAS SHOT IN THE LEG.
>> WOW.
>> AND HOW LONG WERE YOU IN
LOCKDOWN FOR?
DID YOU HEAR ANYTHING WHILE YOU
WERE IN LOCKDOWN?
>> UM, THERE WAS GENERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS BEING MADE
THROUGHOUT.
AND WE WERE LOCKED DOWN FOR
ABOUT AN HOUR.
>> SO, WHAT -- THE -- THE TWO
SHOTS THAT YOU HEARD OR WHAT YOU
BELIEVE WERE SHOTS -- IS THAT
THE ONLY SOUND OF GUNFIRE THAT
YOU HEARD?
>> UM, THERE MAY HAVE BEEN OTHER
GUNFIRE.
THOUGH, THOSE WERE THE MOST
MEMORABLE TO ME.
>> AND LOOKING AT A PICTURE THAT
YOU TOOK OF WHAT LOOKS LIKE A
BULLET HOLE WITH A LOT OF CHAIRS
PILED UP.
WHAT IS THAT IMAGE OF?
>> UM, WE MADE THIS BARRICADE
AND THERE WAS A BULLET HOLE THAT
SHOT THROUGH OUR DOOR.
>> SO, THE SHOOTER WAS CLOSE
ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY SHOOT INTO
YOUR CLASSROOM, THROUGH --
THROUGH THE DOOR?
>> YES.
>> WOW.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SAY YOU WENT
INTO LOCKDOWN, WHAT ACTUALLY DID
YOU DO?
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, YOU ARE IN A
CLASSROOM AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
HAD TRAINING ON -- ON THIS.
DO YOU TRY TO HIDE IN DIFFERENT
PLACES?
DO YOU TRY TO -- WHAT'S THE
INSTRUCTION?
>> BASICALLY, WE LOCKED THE
DOOR.
WE HAVE THE JAMMER CALLED A
NIGHT LOCK.
WE BARRICADE IT AS BEST AS WE
CAN.
AND THEN, WE TRY TO HIDE.
>> AND I UNDERSTAND STUDENTS --
SOME STUDENTS WERE TRYING TO ARM
THEMSELVES WITH WHATEVER THEY
COULD FIND.
>> UH-HUH.
YEAH.
WE -- WE GRABBED CALCULATORS.
WE GRABBED SCISSORS AND JUST IN
CASE IF THE SHOOTER GOT IN AND
WE HAD TO ATTACK HIM.
>> WOW.
I -- I CAN'T IMAGINE BEING IN
THAT SITUATION FOR, I THINK YOU
SAID IT WAS LIKE AN HOUR OR SO,
STANDING THERE WITH A CALCULATOR
THINKING YOU MIGHT TRY TO USE
THAT AS A WEAPON OR SCISSORS OR
A BOOK.
HOW WERE THE OTHER STUDENTS
REACTING?
>> UM, SOME WERE CRYING.
SOME WERE TRYING TO SUPPORT
OTHERS.
OTHERS WERE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH SOME IDEAS JUST IN CASE.
>> AND I KNOW YOU HAVE HAD
TRAINING ON THIS.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, WHEN IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS, IT'S -- YOU KNOW,
THERE'S NOTHING THAT CAN REALLY
PREPARE YOU FOR IT.
>> UH-HUH.
>> WHAT -- WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR
YOU?
>> IT WAS INSANE.
UM, THE VERY FIRST THING IN MY
HEAD WAS THIS IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING?
I'M GOING TO TEXT MY FAMILY, SAY
I LOVE THEM JUST IN CASE IF I
WERE TO DIE.
AND THEN, AFTER EVERYTHING KIND
OF CALMED DOWN FOR A SECOND, I
WAS ABLE TO, LIKE, GET MY BREATH
AND KIND OF RATIONALIZE THINGS.
>> HMM.
AND -- AND LOOKING ON IT NOW, I
MEAN, IT MUST SEEM -- WHAT DOES
IT SEEM LIKE NOW?
DOES IT SEEM JUST AS INSANE?
>> YEAH, IT'S DEFINITELY GOING
TO BE WEIRD COMING BACK,
ESPECIALLY WITH KNOWING THAT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INJURED AND
THAT THERE ARE A FEW STUDENTS
WHO HAVE DIED AS WELL.
>> ADEN, I'M SO SORRY FOR WHAT
YOU AND THE OTHER STUDENTS WENT
THROUGH.
AND I -- I'M GLAD YOU ARE WITH
YOUR FAMILY AND I APPRECIATE
TAKING THE TIME TO TALK TO US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL DEALING
WITH THIS.
EXPECTATIVE NOW FROM CNN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST ANDREW
McCABE.
ALSO, FORMER ASSISTANT DHS
SECRETARY, JULIETTE KAYYEM.
ANDREW, YOU AND I SADLY HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THESE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS MANY TIMES, TOO MANY
TIMES BEFORE.
THE FBI HAS LOOKED CLOSELY, HAS
DONE STUDIES OF ALL THE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS AND A LOT HAS BEEN
LEARNED ABOUT THAT.
THEIR QUICK REACTION TIME, IT
SEEMS LIKE, TODAY, MAY HAVE BEEN
A RESULT OF WHAT WAS LEARNED
FROM COLUMBINE AND OTHERS.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE ACCOUNT FROM
THAT STUDENT ADEN, WHAT STANDS
OUT TO YOU?
>> WELL, AS THE -- AS THE FATHER
OF A 17-YEAR-OLD SENIOR IN HIGH
SCHOOL, I MEAN, IT'S -- IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CHILLING.
AND I -- IT -- YOU KNOW, IT --
IT -- IT -- UM, IT FORCES ME, AS
I HOPE IT DOES EVERY AMERICAN,
TO ASK THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
OF WHY ARE WE PUTTING OUR KIDS
IN THE FIRING LINE WHEN THEY GO
TO SCHOOL?
WHY?
WHAT IS IT ABOUT OUR COUNTRY
THAT WE ARE AWASH IN GUNS AND I
SAY THAT AS A GUNOWNER, AS
SOMEONE WHO CARRIED A GUN FOR 21
YEARS AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
BUT THE FACT IS THAT OUR
SITUATION IN THIS COUNTRY WITH
FIREARMS IS OUT OF CONTROL.
AND THE PERFECT EVIDENCE OF THAT
IS THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE AT RISK
WHEN THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
IT'S JUST HEAD SPINNING.
REALLY IS.
>> JULIETTE, IT'S ALSO -- I
MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, LOOK, WE HAVE
KNOWN ABOUT SCHOOLS HAVING
ACTIVE-SHOOTER TRAINING FOR --
FOR YEARS NOW.
I HAVE GONE TO SCHOOLS WHERE
IT'S DONE TO SEE HOW -- HOW IT'S
DONE UP CLOSE.
JUST THE NORMALNESS OF THIS IS
SO EXTRAORDINARY.
THAT YOUNG MAN HAD HAD MULTIPLE
TRAININGS AND THEY INSTANTLY
KNEW WHAT TO DO, AND THEY TOOK
THEIR POSITIONS AND THEY GRABBED
CALCULATORS AND SCISSORS AND
WHATEVER ELSE THEY COULD WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO FIGHT IF THE -- THE
SHOOTER CAME IN.
>> WITH STAPLERS, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THAT -- THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE.
WE HAVE CREATED THIS NARRATIVE
THAT SOMEHOW WE'RE EQUIPPING
OURSELVES TO DEAL WITH THESE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
SO, WE FIRST TELL KIDS, YOU
KNOW, RUN OR HIDE OR FIGHT.
IN THAT ORDER.
WELL, THEY DID EVERYTHING RIGHT
TODAY AND STILL THREE KIDS DIED.
AND THEN, WE SAY WELL LET'S JUST
TRAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE'LL
HAVE ALL THESE DRILLS AND MAKE
SURE LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN GET
THERE.
WELL, LAST COUNT, 25 AGENCIES
AND 60 AMBULANCES SHOWED UP AT
THE SCHOOL, AND STILL THREE
TEENAGERS DIED.
AND THEN, WE SAY, OH, LET'S PUT,
UM, ARMED GUARDS IN THESE HIGH
SCHOOLS.
WELL, THIS HIGH SCHOOL HAD ONE
THERE AND HE PROBABLY DID A LOT
OF GOOD IN TERMS OF STOPPING THE
VIOLENCE.
STILL, NOT ENOUGH.
I MEAN, THIS IS -- YOU KNOW,
WHAT -- WHAT -- LET'S -- YOU
KNOW, SO I THINK WE JUST REALIZE
NOW THAT -- THAT FIVE MINUTES --
EVERYTHING GOING RIGHT AND
WE'VE -- IN TERMS OF A RESPONSE
AND WE STILL HAVE THREE
TEENAGERS DEAD, FIVE INJURED.
UM, AND -- AND ONE GUN AND ONE
SUSPECT AND THAT'S ALL IT TOOK.
SO, MY FRUSTRATION IS -- IS --
IS WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING MORE AT
THIS STAGE.
>> ANDREW, AGAIN, I GO BACK TO
THAT FAMOUS FBI REPORT AND I
DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF ME.
I HAVEN'T READ IT IN A COUPLE
MONTHS BUT AS I REMEMBER, MOST
DEATHS IN ALL OF THESE SHOOTINGS
TAKE PLACE WITHIN THE
FIRST-SEVERAL MINUTES.
I MEAN, THE KILLINGS TAKE PLACE
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT'S WHY A QUICK REACTION FROM
POLICE IS SO ESSENTIAL BUT AS
JULIETTE SAID, I MEAN, FIVE
MINUTES FROM THE TIME THE 9-1-1
CALL GOES INTO THE TO TIME OF
THE APPREHENSION, THAT'S
INCREDIBLY FAST.
AND YET, ALL THE LIVES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN LOST.
>> EVERY ONE OF THESE INCIDENTS,
ANDERSON, WE STUDY AND WE LEARN
AND WE GET BETTER, RIGHT?
SO, VIRGINIA TECH YEARS AGO
PUSHED THE -- THIS ISSUE OF
GETTING THE FIRST RESPONDERS TO
ACTUALLY ENTER THE BUILDING WITH
LONG GUNS TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT
BACK, THAT SORT OF THING.
OUR FOLKS IN THE FBI CRITICAL
INCIDENT RESPONSE GROUP ALONG
WITH THEIR COLLEAGUES AT DHS
WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN DEVELOPING
THE TRAINING THAT'S NOW BEEN
PUSHED OUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PLACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE REACTIONS OF PEOPLE, OF
VICTIMS ARE BETTER.
THE RESPONSE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS BETTER.
BUT IT IS NEVER GOING TO BE FAST
ENOUGH TO PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING.
AND AS LONG AS GUNS ARE READILY
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, CHILDREN AT HOME TO USING
TO KILL THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
OR -- OR YOUNG,
EMOTIONALLY-CHALLENGED, YOUNG
ADULTS WHO GO INTO HIGH SCHOOL
AND BRING SOMETHING LIKE THAT